And now I'd like to introduce you to our featured presenter today,
uh, Professor Julia Novy-Hildesley.
So Julia is a Professor of the Practice and
the Executive Director of Stanford's Change Leadership for Sustainability Program.
Her research and teaching focuses on business strategies, leadership approaches,
and cross-sector partnerships that spur global development and
align systems with the goal of intergenerational well-being.
Prior to Stanford, Julia served as the Executive Director of the Lemelson Foundation,
the Director of World Wildlife Fund's Pacific Marine Office,
and the CEO of Washington STEM.
Julia holds a BA from Stanford University
and a Masters in Philosophy from the University of Sussex,
where she was recognized as
a distinguished Young Global Leader by the World Economic Forum in 2010.
And with that, let us turn it over to Julia.
Hello and thank you for joining us.
I'm really thrilled to have all of you here
today and to talk about such an important topic,
um, so important in our time,
and really looking forward to the Q&A at the end,
as well to hear some of the perspectives all of
you have regarding this shift we're starting to
see in business as it becomes more and more of the norm to embrace sustainability.
So today we're going to organize our conversation,
uh, around three core themes. There we go.
Okay, so first, why are we seeing this shift in approach?
Why are we seeing more and more businesses,
and organizations in general, embracing sustainability?
Second, uh, what strategic changes are organizations making as they embrace this change?
And finally, how are they actually implementing these changes?
So we're gonna look a little bit at the why,
and the what, and the how, throughout the hour.
Um, first let me share a perspective,
um, as we [LAUGHTER] get into the why here.
You know, what is causing organizations to increasingly embrace sustainability?
And Paul Polman, former CEO of Unilever, uh,
where he was for a decade,
summarizes an insight that is driving the shift.
And fundamentally, he says,
"We must develop a business model aimed at contributing to
society and environment instead of taking from them."
Um, and it's not just Unilever that has this insight of course,
we're seeing organizations and businesses of all varieties,
from small companies to transnationals like Unilever, embracing sustainability.
And not simply as we've seen in the past as an effort to comply with regulations,
or to be charitable through corporate social responsibility initiatives, but really,
um, embracing sustainability as core strategy,
putting sustainability at the heart of a company's business model.
So let's step back a little bit and ask ourselves why are our businesses doing this,
why is this happening,
and why is it happening now.
As we've all experienced firsthand in our personal lives and in our work, um,
we are increasingly operating in an environment characterized by volatility,
uncertainty, complexity, and ambiguity.
And VUCA is- is actually a term that was coined by
the US Army War College to describe
the geopolitical context resulting from the end of the Cold War.
But more recently, it is now used widely in business
to describe the complexity of the operating environment, um, that we're in.
So we could of course devote an entire course to the causes of VUCA World,
but in a nutshell,
VUCA World results from
the fundamentally dynamic and nonlinear interactions
between human beings and the natural environment.
So as we're going about our business,
we are working and living in a vol- a natural environment,
and there are all sorts of feedbacks and interactions that are so complex and non-linear,
that it leads to a lot of this volatility and- and complexity that we're seeing.
And from the human side, we're looking at, you know,
the combination of technology breakthroughs across
a wide variety of fields that had- have impact,
population growth of course,
depletion of natural resources, and climate change,
and also an increasing demand by
the public for transparency and accountability in business.
So all of this is feeding into businesses shifting their approach,
um, to one where sustainability is more embraced.
And, um, what we're starting to see is
that because of the volatility companies are experiencing,
they began to look outward in an effort to understand the sources of disruption may face,
and to determine how best to navigate them.
So this has led many institutions to take more of a systems approach,
recognizing their fundamental interconnectedness to the world around them,
and see not only the extent to which they are impacted by outside forces,
but becoming more and more aware of the breadth and depth of
their own impact on society and the natural environment.
Dr. Paul Polman at Unilever, um,
he talks about the need for companies to see themselves
as part of an interconnected web linking multiple players.
And taking this as perspective as companies do this,
it naturally deepens the responsibility companies feel
and organizations feel towards diverse stakeholders as they become more aware.
Um, and also, um,
it becomes clear that without engagement and collaboration
with stakeholders a lot of these challenges cannot be addressed.
These things are fueling a second shift,
which is the integration of sustainability into core strategy
as a means to mitigate risks that they're facing,
um, but also to strengthen their resilience in the face of VUCA World.
And finally, to also capture value
and- and see the opportunities for creating new value by focusing on sustainability.
So before we go,
um, into more detail,
I want to step back and just say a few words about sustainability,
because it is a term that is often understood differently by different people.
Um, it seems to invoke disparate reactions from different communities.
Um, and I think a starting place for thinking about
sustainability is the framing Jane Jacobs offers,
when she reminds us that the economy is
a wholly owned subsidiary of the environment and not the other way around.
We really can't have an economy without an environment,
all of the inputs come from our environment.
Um, yet sustainability is really not environmental term,
or a green concept as- as we've tended to think of it in the past.
In fact, it's a very human concept.
Uh, sustainability is about building a society that
provides for the long-term well-being of its people.
And this requires us to recognize our fundamental dependence on the natural world,
and to know that we must generate social,
economic, and environmental value in order to thrive.
So we like to use the term intergenerational well-being to describe sustainability,
because we're talking about the well-being of all people,
not just a privileged few,
and we're talking about building a society where we can provide for that well-being,
not just today, but across generations.
[NOISE] Uh, the online course in our strategies
for sustainability program includes extensive interviews with Kate Brandt,
Google Sustainability Officer and Adam Lowry,
Co-founder of Method Cleaning Products and Ripple Foods.
And what I wanted to do is just incorporate throughout this webinar,
three brief clips, um,
from those interviews that you'll see in more, uh,
completion on the online course to give you a few industry perspectives,
people who are grappling with this in their own companies,
because so many of you are doing the same.
So let's turn to a- a brief clip and hear their perspective on,
uh, why we're seeing a shift in business approach.
Business needs to have
a broader perspective around the innovation that it's providing [MUSIC].
And at- at a very basic level,
we're living in a time where a lot of the social contract
between business and societies is broken down.
And a lot of that, I would argue is because of
a hyper focus on shareholder primacy, right?
When you put shareholders in front of anyone else, and then,
yeah you've got some policymakers in your back pocket,
then the outcome sometimes are things that aren't good for the population as a whole.
And rightfully so, people get angry about that, right?
What I'm trying to do with my businesses and many other people are trying to do is
try to build in enlightened corporate governance into that model of innovation,
so that what gets innovated is inherently better for society and environment as well.
And if- that's a design exercise.
And if you can do that well,
and then you can grow a business focusing not just on one thing,
which is shareholder return,
but a broader set of things which makes managing
and leading a business more complex and a little harder.
But if you can do that and do that well,
then you're achieving the goal.
There is increased motivation for
companies to shift toward sustainability for a few reasons.
I think generally there is now
an expectation that businesses will serve a social purpose.
You know, we heard that from Larry Fink in his shareholder letter.
Uh, that is a tremendous shift.
And I think that's led to, you know,
much more executive engagement from corporate leaders,
and philanthropy, and advocating for social environmental causes.
And I think it's led to a lot more activity within companies are really having
very robust sustainability programs that I think are really geared towards, you know,
expectations from customers, from employees,
and from investors, that- that we're seeing increasingly that, you know,
you need to have time-bound goals,
you need to be incorporating this into your operations,
and increasingly incorporate into
your business strategy and making it part of how you think about generating value.
I think that today's operating environment is
really requiring businesses to take more of a systems approach,
and I think that's both because we are increasingly facing greater risks.
So looking at changing climate,
constraints on water, constraints on other natural resources,
and its sustainability is a really critical way to assess those risks,
to do scenario planning,
and to develop new strategies in the face of a world that's changing before our eyes.
Equally, I think there's a lot of opportunity.
You know, when we think about developing more circular business models, uh,
where we're designing waste out of systems,
that creates tremendous new opportunities,
new opportunities for value.
Thanks. So to complement their perspectives,
I wanna just delve in briefly to looking at
the perspective of various stakeholder groups,
investors, customers, and employees, and see,
you know, how are they perceiving the role of business now?
Are there, are we starting to see shifts in that way that might also be contributing to,
uh, the reason that business is becoming to embrace sustainability.
Uh, so let's, let's turn first to investors.
You heard Kate Brandt mentioned Larry Fink.
Uh, in 2018, Larry Fink,
the CEO of BlackRock,
the world's largest investment manager,
gave a wake-up call to corporate CEOs when he wrote in
his annual letter to BlackRock's investees announcing that,
"A company's ability to manage environmental, social,
and governance matters demonstrates the leadership and
good governance that is so essential to sustainable growth,
which is why we are increasingly integrating these issues into our investment process."
That was, that was a big wake-up call,
uh, for companies, and, and of course,
a lot of companies had already perceived that, uh, shift in,
in requirement and recognized the benefits of, uh,
reporting on environmental, social, and governance issues.
If we look at, um, the data,
85 percent of companies now produce and share ESG reports with investors,
which is up from only 20 percent in 2011,
that's a pretty big change in a few years,
and now we've got more data that demonstrates that
positive ESG performance is correlated,
uh, with a lower cost of capital,
better operational performance, and higher stock price.
Let's turn to employees and look at what they're saying.
So, uh, they're putting similar pressure on companies,
younger generations in particular,
who make up the largest population in the workforce
expect businesses to do much more than turn a profit.
Eighty-three percent of millennials and 80 percent of
generation Z employees believe
that business success should be measured in terms of more than financial performance.
Millennials also believe that employers are generally out of sync with them.
When they were asked to identify,
the millennials were asked to identify three priorities for business,
job creation, improving society and enhancing livelihoods,
and improving the environment rose to the top.
Um, well, millennials say their company's top three priorities are profit generation,
driving efficiency, and producing goods.
These happen to be the three lowest priorities on the millennials' list.
Customers too see business as responsible for improving society.
Eighty-five percent of people surveyed across 20 countries hold
companies they buy from accountable for improving their lives.
The same level of expectation they have of government where we traditionally thought,
um, the institutions we've traditionally thought
were responsible for improving our lives.
So what we're seeing is,
as companies start experiencing more and more of the realities of VUCA world,
as well as these heightened expectations of diverse stakeholders,
they're increasingly integrating new perspectives as
they take the system's approach and look beyond themselves, um,
they're engaging with more diverse stakeholders, uh,
that they now see the deep connection they have with and ultimately
recognizing that pursuing sustainability can
drive innovation and long-term value creation.
So here's what we can hear from an industry perspective.
Method was a business that I started in 2000.
We raised $25 million of capital.
uh, when that business got sold,
it achieved multiples in that sale that were far
beyond businesses that had not filled sustainability into their business models.
The shareholders, the employees,
they all made more money financially because the business
we- explicitly because the business was sustainable, not in spite of it.
The business has since grown,
the business has since sold again,
and those shareholders have made more money
because of the type of business that Method is,
not in spite of it.
So it's a very real example of shareholder value.
I mean, we could just measure it on shareholder primacy alone has been higher because
the business focuses on social outcomes and the environment, not in spite.
Thank you so much. So, um,
I just wanna shift now back to Unilever and,
and mention that Paul Polman took quite a similar tact to
the one Adam Lowry is describing, um,
when he questioned the traditional notion that generating
profits must be the primary purpose of business,
ultimately the end, leading to societal benefit.
Rather, he argued that it was the other way around.
By focusing first on improving lives and generating genuinely sustainable solutions,
companies would be profitable over the long term.
The new operating system for business, he argued,
would drive growth through innovations that bring
new sustainability benefits to consumers and retailers,
lower cost by reducing waste and energy use,
and help manage supply chain risk by securing
long-term sustainable sourcing of materials.
And he called for a shift in focus from shareholders,
just like the shareholder primacy Adam Lowry talks about, to all stakeholders.
He says, "I don't think our fiduciary duty is to put shareholders first.
I say the opposite.
What we firmly believe is that if we focus our company on improving the lives
of the world's citizens and come up with genuine sustainable solutions,
we are more in sync with consumers and society,
and ultimately, this will result in good shareholder returns."
So he's really flipping our traditional understanding
and mirroring what we heard from millennials,
which is, a lot of companies just seem to be out of sync with their priorities.
Paul Polman is focusing on getting in sync.
So let's turn from the 'why',
our first question, uh,
in this webinar, to the 'what'.
What are some of the concrete changes that
organizations are making as they embrace sustainability?
Organizations are changing the way they do business across many areas,
but I'd like to highlight three primary ones here and then provide some examples of each.
They're adopting business models and practices to focus on sustainability,
they're innovating to create sustainable products and brands,
and they're also partnering, often,
with competitors to drive scaled impact.
Alongside Method and Google,
there are a few but certainly growing number of companies
experimenting with and adopting circular economy approaches.
Uh, let's take a brief look at a couple of
examples to illustrate the potential of circular models.
These are just two of many,
uh, but let's start with Michelin.
Uh, Michelin has transitioned from a product to a service-oriented business model.
By leasing rather than selling tires,
the company stays engaged with customers because
it has that continuous engagement with them,
rather than just selling your product and saying goodbye,
and then can gather customer feedback and informed product innovation more efficiently.
By controlling its products through leasing rather than selling,
good tires can be recovered and released,
and end of life cycle tires can be
recycled into playgrounds surfaces or converted into fuel.
The company has 97 percent recycling rates in the EU and Brazil,
and this is something that's much more possible because it is
controlling the supply by leasing rather than selling.
Caterpillar has a global network of
re-manufacturing facilities and takes back millions of end of life units.
That's each year, um,
which requires 85 to 95 percent less energy than new production,
and which reduces, of course,
waste and the need for virgin resources.
A growing number of companies such as Eileen Fisher,
a lot of companies you know,
Warby Parker, Ben and Jerry's,
Etsy, Seventh Generation, Method, you've heard about,
have become certified benefit corporations or B corporations,
as a way to operate under a legal requirement to integrate social,
economic, and environmental values and goals.
B corporations are for profit entities just like C corporations, but they, uh,
are required legally to meet
the highest standards of verified social and environmental performance,
and to consider the impact of their decisions on all stakeholder groups,
not just shareholders, including their workers,
customers, suppliers, community, and the environment.
There are now 3,000 B corporations across about 150 industries and 60 corporations.
Several multinationals, it's quite interesting to see, including;
Procter and Gamble, Unilever, Danone, General Mills,
and others have recently accelerated their acquisition of the corporations,
um, and they say they're, they're using these sustainability innovators,
these B Corporations, int- integrating them within
their own companies to help accelerate their own learning on environmental,
social, and governance issues,
to figure out how to drive sustainable product and brand creation.
Um, and David illustrates the financial benefits of the B Corporation approach.
B Corporations averaged to
50 percent revenue growth rate during the 2008 financial crisis and
had a higher revenue growth rate than public firms of
comparable size throughout the subsequent great recession,
according to a 2018 study conducted at Yale University.
Um, let's hear a little bit more from, from Adam and Kate.
So both of the businesses that I have started,
Method products and Ripple Foods are B Corps.
Uh, they're both certified B Corps and benefit corporations both in Delaware.
And what's been interesting is the journey.
I think with Method, we,
we were one of the founding B Corp back in 2007.
I forget exactly where we were on the rating scale which goes from 0-200.
I think we're right around a hundred and or maybe high 90s to begin with.
The businesses is now at 142, and its,
I believe the highest if not- if not,
it's one of the highest manufacturing businesses highest rated B Corps in the world,
and a lot of that is a function of some of the things that
we've been able to do as we've grown.
The most shining example of that would be building
a sustainable manufacturing facility in the inner city of Chicago
to make all of Methods products for North America.
And this is a facility that's renewably powered with utility-scale wind and solar,
uh, it's water neutral,
it's landfill-free, it's got
the largest rooftop greenhouse in the world growing leafy greens on its roof,
growing vegetables in a food desert.
So really cool example.
Those are the types of things that you can do as you start to
achieve some scale and you have a bigger balance sheet,
you can do more and more interesting things.
And importantly, those are things that are not
just done so that I can sit here and talk about them.
Those are things that actually lower
the cost structure of the manufacturing of the business.
They improve our, uh,
vacancy rates and truancy rates on,
uh, line workers at the factory.
They're hard financial metrics that
those sustainability investments or allowing a method to enjoy now,
am, you know, and that's reflected in a B Corps score,
and that's the way it should be.
If you do the right things that should accrued all three bottom lines,
it should get reflected in how you
measure yourself from a social and environmental standpoint.
So let's shift now to sustainable products,
the third area, I mentioned we- we'd explore.
Companies are recognizing the growing opportunity for
sustainable product innovation as consumers increasingly prefers sustainable options,
and consumer demand is also moving as the population changes to emerging markets,
where needs are often related directly to sustainability,
access to water, sanitation, etc.
So what we're starting to see is companies are really taking
off in terms of capturing the value that's possible through sustainable,
um, product and brand innovation,
but also some interesting efforts to really work collaboratively with partners on
the ground to pair sustainable products and brands
with campaigns that create positive social and environmental impact.
So let's look at Unilever as an example in India.
Um, the company recognized that cholera, typhoid,
and skin and eye infections were the leading causes of child mortality.
So it designed, it innovated a new product like buoy soap,
which is a water-saving soap because this happens to be in a very arid region,
but also with 10 times the protection against
the specific disease-causing germs that we're the ones causing these,
these mortal, um, diseases for, for children.
And then what they did is after innovating the product,
they partner with local governments, NGOs,
and a network of 70,000 rural women to
integrate product marketing and distribution with hand washing campaigns,
um, reaching millions of households and dramatically reducing childhood disease rates.
[NOISE] Unilever, um, has developed 26 of these sustainable living brands,
what they call their sustainable living brands,
which grew 46 percent faster than the rest of the business and delivered
70 percent of the company's overall growth in 2017.
Now, um, some challenges are, um,
certainly too big for one company to tackle alone and
even one sector of corporations to
tackle alone really if they require partnership across civil society,
government, and the private sector.
Um, and so what we're starting to see is
more and more companies recognizing this and forging alliances.
Um, Often engaging in pre-competitive problem solving,
um, to shift their sectors towards sustainability for collective benefit.
I'll just give a few examples and these are certainly very complex,
uh, systems challenges, uh,
with no simple answers,
but this will give you a sense of,
of what some companies are doing in partnership with government and civil society.
The Consumer Goods Forum, for example,
is a network of 400 retailers and manufacturers across 70 countries.
They represent four trillion dollars in combined sales,
and they're working together to reach net,
uh, zero net deforestation in their supply chains.
So palm oil has been a big issue that many of you have probably heard about,
leading to a lot of deforestation of very important rain forests in Indonesia.
The Consumer Goods Forum and network of retailers there are,
are working with Indonesian government and other international agencies,
civil society, and a range of,
of palm oil plantations to try to remove deforestation out of the supply chain,
figure out how else to grow palm oil,
um, that is less, less disruptive.
And because they're, they're working on this together,
no one company necessarily will lose
competitive advantage if they step up first and say okay we're going to do this,
but the other companies operate businesses usual,
uh, that, that first leader may lose competitive advantage,
while doing this together and making a shared commitment and working on the challenge,
it allows for greater innovation and also,
um, creates more incentive for everyone to move in the right direction.
The Marine Stewardship Council is another initiative.
I've worked on the MSC very, um,
intensely about 20 years ago when it was being launched by
Unilever and World Wildlife Fund, and,
and the vision is really to create an economic incentive for sustainable fishing through
certification and eco-labeling of well-managed fisheries
so that products from this fisheries would have chain of custody,
verification, end up in our restaurants or
grocery stores and being marked with eco-labeling you see there,
to indicate to all of us that they came from sustainable sources.
And many of you probably know the state of our oceans is dire,
um, global fisheries are- have been collapsing worldwide for, for decades,
and the MSC offers a similar opportunity to bring government, business,
and civil society together to create an organization that is,
is driving, uh, for positive change.
There are currently about 10 percent of fisheries worldwide
certified as, as MSC sustainable.
Finally, um, the Sustainable Apparel Coalition
has created a set of standardized tools to help companies in
the apparel textile and footwear industry
measure environmental and social impacts across their supply chains,
allowing to achieve much greater transparency and address,
uh, the unsustainable behavior collectively.
And as I mentioned none of these efforts is simple nor is any of them
without unintended consequence- consequences and trade-offs.
Um, companies in the Consumer Goods Forum, for example,
don't have clear ways to engage the thousands of
smallholder farmers who are growing oil palms,
yet without them, deforestation will continue.
So it's really an effort that is,
is very complex and,
um, certainly, um, has not yet reached scale in terms of success,
and none of these three, but it is an avenue through
which change can happen and in which systems change can happen,
um, and we don't really think there was a kind [LAUGHTER] of a way to do it,
it's just important to acknowledge how complex and challenging it is.
[NOISE] So let's, um,
shift now to a bit of the how.
We've talked about why businesses are shifting their approach.
We're talking- we've talked a bit about some of
the strategic changes organizations are making,
you know, what exactly are they doing when they embrace sustainability?
But also, it's really important to think about how
our organizations going about this internally?
How are they implementing these changes and what barriers
are they coming up against as they try to make the shift?
So, um, let's take a look inside Unilever to explore this.
Um, in 2010, Unilever launched a 10-year Sustainable Living Plan or SLP,
covering all aspects of its business,
incorporating all brands and divisions in every country where it works, um,
and SLP outlined three 10 year goals
aligned with its purpose to make sustainable living commonplace.
So at that time in 2010,
Unilever revisited its purpose and really focusing on,
you know, our corpus as an organization is to make sustainable living commonplace.
And so they frame these three, um,
big 10-year goals as part of the Sustainable Living Plan.
They said they first want to help more than one billion people,
improve their health and well being.
We have that briefcase of the Lifebuoy soap as an example.
They said they want to have the environmental footprint of Unilever products.
And third, they want to source
100 percent of their agricultural raw materials sustainably,
and back to the oil palm growers I mentioned,
enhance the livelihoods of millions of people across the value chain, you know,
if- how do you really take responsibility at
that level for your entire value chain all the way down to the growers?
So, um, they also have taken this very seriously in terms of, um,
establishing targets and, um,
sub goals under each of these major goals.
So, for example under health and hygiene, or under, um,
health and well being,
they've established goals around health and hygiene and improving nutrition.
Under reducing environmental impact,
they've set goals and targets around greenhouse gases,
water use, waste and packaging,
and, uh, in, and a sustainable sourcing.
And then finally under enhancing livelihoods,
they've set goals and targets in term- terms of fairness in the workplace,
opportunities for women, and inclusive business.
Progress against the targets is measured and reported in
Unilever's annual report and accounts to shareholders.
So they've been very transparent about
both the goal setting and the metrics and targets they're using,
but also on reporting on an annual basis,
um, in public forum, how they're doing.
So, um, in order to do the work and this goes back to
the internal work I- I talked about in introducing the section of the webinar, um,
in order to align the company behind the sustainable living plan,
Unilever needed to revisit its internal systems and
processes and reorient corporate behavior.
Look for where things were aligned with this goal and look at
where they have processes or systems that worked against,
um, the goals they stated and figure out what to do about it.
So, for example, Unilever has tied,
um, since it launched SLP,
tied remuneration and performance evaluations
to achieving the objectives of the sustainable living plan.
Um, it's removed incentives for short term profit maximization,
um, by deciding not to publish quarterly reports.
There are very few publicly traded companies have made that decision, but there's, um,
actually recent data that demonstrates that those companies that have,
actually have better performance because they
aren't driven by decision making for short term,
um, short term results to report to shareholders.
They also established two board committees whose sole responsibility, uh,
is to provide top-down oversight on the implementation of the sustainable living plan.
And also all internal and external
communications and human resources activities include SLP,
making sure that across this massive corporation,
all the employees are hearing about,
um, this priority and feeling a part of it.
Perhaps, most importantly, the company supports
ongoing learning and adaptation by engaging employees.
It's one thing to learn about it through communications,
but it's another thing to be engaged as an employee, um,
as a manager, as a supply chain partner,
in the process of designing and implementing practices that support the SLP.
So for example, uh,
employees work directly on
the company's global wellness efforts such as the Dove Soap Self-esteem Project,
um, or the Help A Child Reach 5 campaign,
deepening their commitment to the sustainable living plan,
and deepening their understanding.
Unilever managers also work across the organization and in partnership with
suppliers and distributors to conduct life-cycle assessments of their product lines,
so that they can evaluate
social and environmental impacts and determine changes that need to be made.
So what about progress?
It's one thing to set goals and targets and, um,
it all looks great, but actually,
um, how is Unilever doing?
Um, it's actually on track to meet around 80 percent of
its sustainable living plan commitments across its three major goals by 2020.
Um, by the end of 2017,
Unilever had reached 601 million people through its programs on hand-washing,
sanitation, oral health, self-esteem,
and safe drinking water against the target of 1 billion.
It had reduced its waste by 29 percent against it's target of 50 percent,
sourced 56 percent of its products sustainably,
as verified by third-party certifiers,
against its target of 100 percent, and finally, um,
it had exceeded its target to engage at least 500,000 smallholder
farmers in its supply network to improve their agricultural practices,
reaching actually 716,000 farmers.
So interestingly, rather than suffering, um,
from this new business approach,
much as Adam Lowry said,
Unilever has continued to perform well.
Um, Unilever's share prices outperformed the Euronext
100 and the FTSE 100 Indices consistently over the past nine years.
And just stepping back,
Unilever offers one perspective on how to create
a business model focused on sustainability by defining new goals and metrics,
innovating sustainable products and brands,
and aligning its internal systems and processes to support this new business model.
Um, maybe your organization's quite different, um,
but what would long-term business goals focused on sustainability look like for you?
Um, what does sustainability mean in your context?
And- and where does sustainability offer opportunities for growth,
or risk mitigation, value creation?
How might some of Unilever's changes in internal practices be
relevant and doable in the context of your organization?
So stepping back, we began with these three core questions for the webinar.
You know, why are we starting to see the shift in- in approach where
businesses are- are really starting to pursue and embrace sustainability?
What are some of the strategic changes organizations are making?
There are obviously a multitude; we looked at a few.
Um, and how are they going about implementing these changes?
What- what are some of the nu- nuts and bolts of- of
actually trying to do this in context?
Um, and- and what we saw is,
you know, for the first question,
we're- we've got businesses responding to the reality of VUCA world,
of changing stakeholder expectations,
definitely heightened expectations of the role of business in improving lives,
in solving social challenges,
and tackling 21st century global, um, global challenges.
Um, but also that, uh, sustainability,
i- it has a real role to play in helping businesses
mitigate risk and lower cost and drive growth.
Um, under the second,
we looked at some new business practices including circular economy,
um, pursuing B corporation status,
um, to sustainable products and sector-wide partnerships.
And then we looked at how Unilever in particular is aligning goals, um, processes,
and incentives to really support, um,
support its- its objectives around sustainability,
to really walk the talk internally
to make it possible to make progress against these goals.
And so just here at the end before we move to Q&A,
I wanna just step back and- and look at these broader shifts we are seeing,
uh, in society with respect to business.
Um, what we talked about today is part of
a larger evolution that's been going on for decades,
where we're- we're seeing companies move from this focus
on compliance and corporate social responsibility,
um, to one where sustainability is actually a strategy.
It's not just a charitable act or something we gotta do to comply with regulations.
It's actually a strategy for doing well.
Um, and as we heard from many, Adam Lowry,
and Paul Polman, and others,
this shift from focusing, uh,
on shareholder primacy to one of really seeing
the whole network of stakeholders companies are connected to,
um, and impacting and being impacted by.
And then also short-term profit,
moving more towards long-term value creation.
Um, how do we endure over the long-term,
generate value, have relevance,
live up to the responsibility that we have as
a business in this changing world that is so
volatile and ambiguous, um, and complex.
And- and finally, how do we start thinking now about not just company leadership,
being a great leader as a- as a company in your, in your sector,
but also leading your sector through global partnerships?
How do we, how do we move full sectors, you know,
to better practice and- and actually partner with
some of our competitors to make that happen?
And that leads to the final point,
which is rather than competitiveness, you know,
being supreme, we're starting to see a- a real recognition that the collaboration is key.
And just to close, I think, you know,
I wanna share the message that I think in order for business to
really fully capitalize on the opportunities that sustainability presents,
and to play the leading role it must in tackling 21st century global challenges,
these shifts that we described today that- that really
aren't as mainstream as- as we'd like them to be,
really need to become universal cultural norms,
simply the way things are done in the 21st century.
And all of you listening today,
thank you for your time.
I'm really looking forward to your questions,
but you have a really important role to play in this.
Wherever you are in your organization,
whatever position, you can start by asking curious questions.
You can start by taking a systems perspective and being
sure others around you are seeing the way in
which your organization is so fundamentally connected
to other stakeholders and the natural environment,
the social and cultural and historic context.
Um, and you can start demonstrating opportunity through
cost-saving measures that you might identify within your units,
or incredibly great value creation opportunities through-
through new product design that's actually really meeting a social or environmental need,
um, that has broader value.
So look forward to hearing your questions and- and thanks so much for your attention.
Okay. Great. So now we'll move on to answering your questions.
So clearly, you know,
we have an audience that is really experienced and knowledgeable about the topic.
Um, what you've presented really resonated with, um, you know,
their thoughts and their views on,
uh, sustainability and corporate strategy.
Um, and we've gotten, you know,
a- a few questions really around,
kind of, the specifics of implementation.
You know, the challenges, the barriers and all of that.
So one of the questions that we got from participants is that, you know,
this line of thinking is really great for companies engaged in manufacturing,
you know, resources, and traditional industries.
Are there any examples and,
you know, are there any ways, um,
as to how a company that's in
a service industry can kind of engage and help out with this initiative?
You know, for example, a company that's in financial services,
and business services, how can they contribute to this effort?
Yeah. Great question. And certainly,
I would argue that it is universally relevant, but certainly,
um, needs to be interpreted and
manifested differently depending on what kind of company or sector or industry you're in.
So absolutely great question.
Um, I think Google, uh, we didn't hear as
much from Kate as you will in the online course,
um, in- in my short clips,
but she talks a lot about their emphasis and, you know,
using Google advantage where they have, you know,
incredible advantage in AI and machine learning and Cloud computing,
and pull those together to generate incredible cost-savings, um,
billions of dollars in, uh,
the heating and cooling of their,
the cooling in particular of their data centers.
Um, and so it really,
you gotta sit where you're- where you are.
I- Google also, you know,
it's not just cost savings,
um, from a sustainability standpoint,
they focus their first and,
you know, focusing on using,
just having purely renewable energy source in their company.
Um, but they also move towards societal benefit.
You know, how can we actually use our tools to generate benefit for society?
So they've actually innovated this interesting, um,
tool called Global Fishing Watch where they've taken their GPS,
um, capacity, combined it with, um,
machine learning, with an algorithm that would help them identify,
um, getting data, using, you know,
just getting masses of data from around the world on- on boats out on the ocean,
and then being able to identify which boats are actually fishing boats,
versus cargo, vessels, et cetera.
Uh, and then being able to see where fishing boats are actually actively fishing,
and if in fact they're fishing illegally, helping governments,
helping empower governments to really protect their fisheries more effectively.
So it's- depends what industry you're in and how you can combine your talents and
your skills and your advantages and your- your tech know
how to- to find the right solutions that work for your company.
I think related to the service question in particular,
I mean Michelin is an interesting example where it was a product-driven company,
and Philips just shifted too from selling light- lighting services,
um, from shifting to pro- from products to selling light as a service.
Um, and Michelin's leasing tires so that they're controlling
that- that, um, that product.
So a lot of companies are shifting to,
um, from product to service models,
and I think there are ways in which any company can- can make that shift.
Great. So the simple question that we have is, you know,
as a lot of more companies are paying more attention to this topic, they're reporting,
they're redesigning products, you know,
their branding is more aligned with the suitability message overall.
There's also kind of criticism that comes up, you know,
where people are mentioning or accusing companies of green-washing,
you know, their practices,
their products, and etc.
So, you know, how can we hold corporations accountable and,
you know, as consumers or as civil society,
what are some of the metrics and things out we can look for to really identify
whether a company is simply "green-washing" or are they actually,
uh, you know, uh,
dedicated to this effort?
Well, it- it's a great question and it's a huge challenge.
We faced it early on with the Marine Stewardship Council as
soon as we launched the Marine Stewardship Council which,
you know, we took a lot of time to develop the global standard for sustainable fishing.
It was based on the UN FAO code of conduct,
which had existed for many years.
It was a very high standard, uh,
and scientifically validated in terms of, okay,
this is really a good definition of a well-managed fishery.
Well, as the MSC label gained traction,
a number of industry labels came up,
where industry then created its own label
for sustainable fishing and put that on on products.
And so it really took education of consumers,
and I- I think that's what it is.
It's education of consumers,
it's testing these different labels and really
getting the truth about what- what is behind the label,
what does it really mean.
Um, and that is, yes,
as the person who asked the question acknowledges, it's-it's very complex.
I- one thing that was really important for
the Marine Stewardship Council was to have the World Wildlife Fund.
You know, WWF panda logo,
alongside Unilever when the- when
the organization first launched because it gained credibility,
um, and it held that standard to a very high level.
And- and then once the tent widened and many many more NGOs became involved,
those NGOs made sure that that standard stayed high and appropriate.
And many times pushed the MSC saying the standard wasn't high enough
and the fishery that got certified shouldn't have been certified, and challenged them.
So this is the complexity of the work,
but- but it needs to be done and I think,
you know, new technology offers some benefit.
I think we will be able to trace chain of custody more easily now with
block chain and with other technologies that will help us ensure that um,
we know about the products that we're buying and we know more about them.
But yes, great-great question.
Right. So another question is that, you know,
our participants- participants come from a variety of different companies,
you know, from different industries and at different scales.
So a lot of times, you know,
the companies that are getting
the most exposure through these initiatives are the large corporations.
You know, these are multinational corporations,
these are very big,
uh, companies that have reached into many different industries and products.
So how can we get smaller or medium-sized businesses to be more engaged,
or join these initiatives led by these larger corporations and how can,
you know, small and medium businesses contribute to this effort?
So when you say join these initiatives,
what are you referring to?
So for example, with, you know,
the consumer uh, that- the forums that you've talked about,
you know, with MSC.
You know a-a lot of transect companies that are represented
in these initiatives are large, multinational corporations.
Um um.
So how can small and medium-sized businesses also participate?
Well, I think it's absolutely essential that they do
because the sector is complex and that,
you know, well there's a lot of consolidation,
and a lot of control um,
and market share within the larger companies,
the smaller companies are- are essential and play a vital role.
And in fact, in the case of the oil palm example,
it really is, you know,
one of the challenges is,
what do you do with thousands and thousands of
farmers who don't have a clear alternative,
and is Unilever going to take care and
make sure that their farming practices are sustainable,
and their livelihoods are secured,
because if not, they have only one way to support themselves,
which is to continue to cut the forest,
and- and grow either food or- or oil palm for- for- for engaging the cash economy.
So um, it is absolutely essential that-that all scales are engaged and I think,
you know, some smaller companies can play a leadership role.
I- I think about Sustainable Harvest Coffee Company and they, you know,
they are a small operator within the huge coffee,
relatively consolidated coffee industry, and they said,
"we're going to have a different model, we're going to have a
relationship coffee model," which is basically,
you know, we are going to take the linear supply chain, and make it circular,
and we are going to have every grower that we worked
with part of a team that is connected to roasters,
and bankers and um, retailers,
so that everybody in the supply chain
knows what the reality of doing business is like um,
for each stakeholder group in the supply chain.
And- and they have built that model,
they have Let's Talk Coffee events that they host,
um and they innovate it every year in a coffee growing country.
And now, all the big players are coming,
McDonald's is coming, you know, Walmart is coming.
They want to understand- and- and Sustainable Harvest
created that platform as a very small company that said, "You know,
we're a big corporation,
we have a different business model,
we put 50 percent of profit back into farmer training,
um, and we believe in transparency."
They will not do business with anyone unless
every transaction in the entire supply chain is transparent.
So from farmer to roaster and retailer,
every transaction is transparent and um,
and that's allowed them to build these trusting relationships,
and- and shift the way business is done,
um, for this segment of the coffee industry.
So small companies can- can play a very disruptive and- and positive role.
Right. So we're getting really close to an hour right now,
we have time for one last question.
So um, this question specifically concerns kind of your experience and your perspective.
So Julia, you've worked with,
you know, a lot of different sectors,
you've worked on partnerships between government and- and business,
and- and industry with companies of different size.
So-so do you see, you know,
certain business sectors or certain industries being more
receptive to this change than others and conversely,
you know, which industries,
or which sectors are you seeing the greatest resistance?
Well, it's a great question.
Um, you know, I think what is interesting is to see
how different issues engage different stakeholders and- and how that happens.
I mean, is it because you get a green-peace campaign and you're
forced to deal with the palm oil challenge,
which was-was the case for Nestle and Unilever,
when they launched the video?
Um or is it that, you know,
you have an enlightened leader who really wants to take responsibility and has-has
insight into some of the impacts the company is having or a combination?
Um, I think about a lot of the um,
chemical companies and things,
who are starting to get more and more engaged because of the plastics issue.
So maybe some traditional industries we thought wouldn't
necessarily engage so much in this issue are really
recognizing as we look at our oceans and they have become
filled with- with plastic, including micro plastics.
The average seafood consumer has- consumes about
11,000 particles of micro plastics per year.
Um, so it's not just the plastic we can
see in the ocean that we know that we're dumping into the ocean,
but it's now all of the micro plastics that are there.
And so companies are starting to recognize responsibility,
and um, I'm working right now on an ocean plastics initiative to-to really say,
how do we get all of
these global actors from throughout the supply chain engaged in this,
from the chemical companies, um,
to the recycling infrastructure, globally, across nations.
Um, so I think really it depends how you look at the- the challenge,
but- but everybody- everybody has a stake and
everybody's connected to the-the problem, and the solution.
So it's just a matter of, you know,
what incites the initial- initial engagement.
Great. So we are on top of the hour right
now and we're going to have to wrap up the Q&A session.
So again, thank you very much Julia
today for sharing your knowledge with our participants.
Um, for those of you who have indicated interest in the program,
our team will definitely be reaching out with more information.
If you have any pressing questions for Julia or about the program,
feel free to reach out to our team as well.
So as a final reminder, you know,
the recording of this webinar will be emailed to you within a week and you
can always visit us at globalimpact.stanford.edu.
So thank you all for joining us today and have a great rest of your week.